Alec Baldwin charged with two counts of
involuntary manslaughter in the Fatal
onset shooting of rust cinematographer
Helena Hutchins there's only one
question to ask here who put a live
round in the gun the actor's attorney
tells E.T they'll fight these charges
and will win claiming that Baldwin had
no reason to believe there was a live
bullet in the gun because he was assured
by the professionals on set one of those
Pros Hannah Gutierrez Reid the film's
armorer who was also charged with two
counts alongside Baldwin her attorney
claims the charges follow quote a very
flawed investigation and inaccurate
understanding of the full facts adding
that since the shooting Hannah's been
very emotional and sad about what they
refer to as a tragic accident do you
feel guilt no no I feel that there is I
I feel that that that
someone is responsible for what happened
and I can't say who that is but I know
it's not
and in the wake of the new charges
Hutchins family is also speaking out the
family's attorney says they support the
charges and thank law enforcement for a
thorough investigation why would anybody
believe that I worked in this business
for 40 years and that day I decided to
play with a gun that's the dumbest thing
I've ever heard meanwhile Baldwins filed
his own civil suit against Gutierrez
read
this all follows Baldwin settling the
wrongful death lawsuit against him in
October filed by the Hutchins family as
part of the settlement it was alleged
that rust would resume filming in a new
location with Hutchins Widow Matthew
serving as executive producer